[music playing]
[splash]
[shout]
NARRATOR: After a
season of frustration--
BEN SHARP: Right there.
--Regina and her team have
a killer whale in sight.
BEN SHARP: He's coming
towards the edge.
NARRATOR: Now, they just
need it to be in range.
REGINA EISERT: Often the
whales pop up out of nowhere.
You've got half a
second to take your aim.
Because the thing's
moving, and you need
to shoot it while it's moving.
And it's only above the water
for a very short period.
BEN SHARP: It's coming
this way, Rowan.
Right there.
[spouts water]
[music playing]
Got it.
All right.
REGINA EISERT: Hey.
BEN SHARP: Awesome.
Perfect.
REGINA EISERT: It's all right.
You're good.
BEN SHARP: There's a little
piece of blubber and skin.
It'll take a little
piece of skin, smaller
than the end of my fingernail.
But that's enough for us
to do genetics and also
stable isotope analysis.
Stable isotopes allow us to
position where the animal is
eating in the food chain, and
so it helps us to reconstruct
what the diet of the whale is.
Once we match those
with the photo IDs,
we start to understand family
structure and population size.
NARRATOR: Information
from a single whale
helps the team learn
about the individual.
But multiple samples help
them understand a section
of the population, and
that's the goal they've
been working toward all season.
BEN SHARP: Regina!
Regina!
REGINA EISERT:
There's the other one.
Success is if you
get any samples.
What we need-- as many
killer whales as we can.
Big male out over here.
BEN SHARP: [sighs] Here he is.
[shot]
Got him?
BEN SHARP: Yep.
He reacted.
So there's a group
right out over there.
BEN SHARP: Then
there's more out there.
REGINA EISERT: I
hate to say it, but I
told you there would be whales.
BEN SHARP: Saw
another one coming.
Go ahead.
Go-- not the other guy.
REGINA EISERT: Where's
the other rifle?
BEN SHARP: Go for the
other gun, right there.
[music playing]
[spout]
[shot]
BEN SHARP: You got her?
I didn't even see it.
Good shot.
REGINA EISERT: I'm very
pleased with our samples,
because it was a lot
of work getting them.
As opposed to some days-- you've
got 50 whales milling around.
And they're just
all over the place,
and you don't know what to
shoot first-- we had to run
up and down the ice edge.
And there was one or
two animals at a time,
and we had to chase them.
[laughs]
BEN SHARP: Well, we
finally saw some whales.
We had to move fast
to get to them.
Here we go.
He's closer.
He's right here.
BEN SHARP: He's right there.
Nice shot.
Regina just got a biopsy
from that second big male
in that group.
Nice.
Right there.
[music playing]
BEN SHARP: We got six biopsies.
REGINA EISERT: Hey!
BEN SHARP: I think we did
really good on the photo IDs.
That first group was the same
group over and over again.
So we probably got that
whole family group.
Regina found a place
where the whales are.
Regina ended up
getting biopsies.
We got good data.
As we work it up, we're going
to be able to do a lot with it.
BEN SHARP: Good day.
All right, we did good.
[spouting]
[music playing]